these roles seem like dream roles for an
actor because you get to explore so much
on an emotional level but at the same
time they're also very intense emotions
so
are these characters that you miss
playing at all especially having had
such a
long break due to covid or are they
characters that you're glad to pack away
for a little bit
back it away a little bit
my character the this season was uh
a tad bit intense the ride was a little
bit intense
yeah
emotionally physically so
you know i'm happy to uh put it down for
a little bit
yeah but personally i feel like i yeah
but
the eight or nine
months that we spend shooting is
definitely enough
time to live in that space and it's nice
to show the skin for a while but it's
also a treat to go back as well
yeah i mean do any of you guys really
miss your character when you don't get
to play them or
are they someone you're glad to not have
to always have a round
i miss being on set and
hanging out with these guys and you know
the camaraderie and the
the connection that we have i miss that
yeah
for my career for my character there's a
certain kind of like honesty and
vulnerability that's uh
nice to um
um
to
to tap into and feel
on a more constant basis
i'm curious austin for you i mean the
the breakup scene between
ethan and kat was one of the most
memorable moments for me in the entire
season
it's it's just such an interesting
dynamic between the two of them she's so
sure she wants to break up with him and
then
tries to fake a terminal illness instead
what was that
whole
scene like to shoot does it feel like a
real sort of defining moment for your
character and their relationship
yeah i would say so like for me that
that scene
is a long scene and there's like
it feels
like a journey into
becoming a man a little bit or just or
just at least growing up a little bit
more
um
because by the end of it you know i feel
like
i
ethan's been trying to make it work
and trying to make the relationship work
for like a while at that point um
and i think there's like an
understanding of like oh i don't think i
like
i want this um anymore
um
yeah so i think by the end of it at
least for me like there was growth
character-wise
and because i i also thought your
character has a really interesting
dynamic with lexi this season
of all the people on this show i mean
why what do you think it is about lexi
that interests him and and why is he so
genuinely interested in her
i mean
i feel like fresco just uh
he hasn't had he hasn't had a lot of
time in his life to um
feel those feelings and put
the energy
uh
put put his energy towards
anything
romantic you know
it just uh
hasn't hasn't been uh uh
a part of his life he hasn't been
available to it you know and um
so it's definitely i feel like uh
him and and and lexi and mod you know um
when when we work together it's like
him uh
really like figuring out uh some of his
own or like tapping into some of his
innocence and
maybe some of like uh
the experiences that he he lost
or missed out on because he had other
responsibilities you know
so um
their relationship is special because
you know
also lexi
her character
probably hasn't had much in the um
realm experience of relationships and
whatnot either because she's so shy and
and whatnot so it it is kind of a
strange pair but it also
works pretty perfect
because um
fiscal's not not an evil bad guy you
know he's really uh he's really a sweet
guy so
you get to see that part of him and i'm
glad i got i got to tap into that part
of
him
jacob the the scene between nate and
maddie in the sixth episode where he
shows up in her room with a gun and then
holding the gun to your head i mean that
that is a scene that really bothered me
and stuck with me so what was it like to
do that to read that do you did you have
to justify his actions to yourself or is
it do you have conversations with sam
about that
um
i think for me it's just you know it's
never about judging what he's doing and
putting myself in sort of the headspace
where i can maybe see how
that's like a feasible outcome or
something that the character would do
um but it was it was a lot it was it was
a really really frightening scene to go
into because you know they're real guns
and
um and so for about the week leading up
to it i was you know it's you kind of
have to start putting yourself in a
space because you know
for me it was like being okay with
killing yourself is sort of what that
scene was for me it's like i'm ready to
go kind of thing so it was it was it was
um yeah it was
it was a lot to sit there and then
actually put the steel to your head is
you know it was um
it was interesting but it was also you
know it was
it was thrilling you know
eric your character has quite the
revelatory monologue this season
so what was it like to explore
essentially like everything he's dealing
with and not expressing all in one
moment it's so much fun at times because
i don't have to deal with real world
consequences
so i get to explore all these behaviors
and
and and and have these moments that uh i
really get to indulge
um without having to
without having to deal with any of the
repercussions you know
that comes with the reality of all that
stuff that kyle's doing um it was very
freeing i found it very freeing
um
this season was a was a was a pretty
wild ride for me
yeah that was definitely a wild moment
you all have some very memorable moments
this season so thank you for talking to
me about it